t
ultime c'est cette chanson.
♪ ♪ ♪
- C'est probablement un des
meilleurs ou un des pires vers
d'oreille de l'histoire de
la musique :
♪ ♪ ♪
La Macarena.
MIKE GAUTHIER,
animateur et journaliste musical
- T'sais, ce qu'on appelle
un one hit wonder, un feu
de paille, un succès sans
lendemain, qui réussit à être
la chanson de l'année.
♪ ♪ ♪
Ça a quand même été numéro 1
durant 14 semaines, ça a été
la chanson de 1996.
♪ ♪ ♪
- La première version de
la Macarena, par Los Del Rio
est sortie en 1992. À l'époque,
elle remporte un certain succès
dans des pays latins.
- Après ça, il y a des Canadiens
qui l'ont reprise. C'est arrivé
chez nous un peu avant et après
ça, ça a été aux États Unis
et c'est là que ça a explosé
à l'échelle mondiale parce
qu'ils ont ajouté un peu
d'anglais dedans.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Un succès immense, repris
en version symphonique,
♪ ♪ ♪
- ... revisité à la sauce rap,
- ... ou même comme chant
de Noël.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Le phénomène est tellement
grand qu'actuellement la maison
où les gars ont vu la fille,
qui les a inspirés, une danseuse
de flamenco, et ça dit : "C'est
dans cette maison-ci que
la Macarena a été créé"
et qu'ils ont vu la danseuse
en question, et tu peux la louer
la maison sur AirBnb. Et ça,
c'est l'amorce pour essayer
de vous convaincre de louer
GENEVIÈVE BORNE,
animatrice
- C'est comme si chaque décennie
a sa chanson latino avec
des mouvements de danse que
les gens prennent plaisir
à apprendre. À la fin des années
"80", il y a eu la "Lambada".
Dans les années 2000, il y a eu
Las Ketchup avec la chanson
"Ketchup". Il y a eu Despacito
dans les année 2010. Dans
les année 90, ça a été
la Macarena. Tout le monde a
appris les mouvements de danse.
Tu t'en souviens?
- Il y a un dénominateur commun
avec plusieurs chansons qui ont
été des hits d'été. C'est
la petite chorégraphie facile
à faire, intergénérationnelle.
Les enfants, les parents et
les grands parents, quand ils
sont à une noce, peuvent danser
ensemble, puis avoir du fun.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Si t'écoutes les paroles,
Nabi, bien, c'est pas pour
les enfants. Parce que ça parle
d'une fille qui est une grande
séductrice et infidèle. Et qui
dit : "Si tu danses bien à
mes côtés, tu vas peut-être
te retrouver dans mon lit..."
- Le duo espagnol Los Del Rio,
continue de surfer sur le succès
de la vague déferlante
"Macarena". Mais le duo n'a
jamais réussi à composer
un autre grand succès.
Cela dit, à certains égards,
ils ont été des précurseurs.
Et maintenant, la musique
latine, elle est partout.
Dans la musique pop, les rythmes
latins sont très, très,
très présents.
- Que l'on considère que c'est
un outil de torture qui devrait
être illégal ou le secret
infaillible pour enflammer
une piste de danse, 25 ans plus
tard, la Macarena continue
de soulever les passions.
♪ ♪ ♪
Ici Nabi-Alexandre Chartier,